what he did let's take you straight to
that an array convention in houston
where greg abbott is speaking the
governor of texas directed him to the
death penalty in texas
well just as laws didn't stop the killer
we will not let his evil acts stop us
from uniting the community that he tried
to destroy
as parents ourselves cecilia and i are
heartbroken by such a senseless tragedy
like this
we urge everyone here today everyone
across the country
to pray for those in uvalde who are
impacted by this atrocious act
the courageous actions of the many
teachers and staff at robb elementary
school
should be applauded
these men and women are heroes for their
fearless defense of the children in
their charge
the lord teaches us
that every child is a precious gift
and evil stole those gifts from their
parents on tuesday and also
remember this
there are thousands of laws on the books
across the country that limit the owning
or using of firearms
laws that have not stopped mad men from
carrying out evil acts on innocent
people
in peaceful communities
in uvalde
the gunman committed a felony under
texas law before he even pulled the
trigger
it's a felony to possess a firearm on
school premises
but that did not stop him
and
what he did on campus
is capital
murder
that's a crime that would have subjected
him to the death penalty in texas
well just as laws didn't stop the killer
we will not let his evil acts stop us
from uniting the community that he tried
to
destroy i'm in uvaldi this afternoon
working to heal the brokenhearted
we will bind up the wounds of the people
of uvalde
and once again restore the luster to a
community
known for its warmth
its friendship
and its values
may god bless the people of yuvaldi
and may god forever bless
the great state of texas